in some scenes you're pregnant well yes
we did some additional photography and
is pregnant and I was kind of still
early so it wasn't really telling anyone
and so tom was confused as to why I
wasn't engaging in all the stunts
because I was kind of game for it when
we did the original shoot and eventually
I went because I'm growing a human and
he was so cute about it and then
protected me was helping me downstairs
so he was almost overboard you know
she's like Tom Tom Tom I'm sorry I can
do stairs you rule it at human and the
human popped out picture of hazel as a
mother that must be so nice to have 600
people Oh was it the nurse that was very
complimentary she was funny we were in
the recovery room up to it and we had
this amazing nurse who came in and she
looked at me she goes Sam your baby is
so cute I went oh really she went she is
gorgeous and I went hit Mabel I think
you say that to all the mothers and she
went no I don't say when I know what
baby ugly I say you had a baby
[Music]